To solve this, I looked at the ratio--the ratio of this side to that side--
and compared it to this and that.
Let's see--over here we have 5 m over 12 m,
and I know that must, must, must be equal to whatever this side is--I'll call it x/18 m.
Again, these units cancel out.
This ratio 5/12 seems to be pretty important.
I'm going to multiply both sides by 18,
and when I carry out this multiplication, I find 7.5 m.
Now, this ratio, 5/12--I'm going to put it in parentheses to show that it's important--
every single time we see a 22.6 degree angle in a right triangle
I know that look at this side over that side will give me this ration 5/12.
That may seem trivial, but it's actually deeply, deeply important.
In fact, since we're going to be using these ratios so often,
let's agree on a way to refer to the sides of a right triangle.